everyone this is Steve on trove with
Collider and I am here with everyone
from fighting with my family thank you
guys so much for coming in today
thank you I should say for people
watching it's 9:30 in the morning it's
very early for Sundance on a Monday
morning exactly I want to start before
we get started I want to give a huge
thank you to Kia Telluride they're our
sponsor the only reason we get to do
this stuff is having a sponsor Sundance
is what we call expensive and I'm just
going to say thank you to Kia jump thank
you it's yesterday they were joking
around that it was a Kia but it's it's
really Kia you know she's up to them I
don't want to pressure them I funny I
think we can actually make that happen
okay great yeah they make cars for six
foot seven you're right
[Laughter]
first of all I want to start by saying
how much I enjoyed this movie you guys
were all great I think it's gonna be
like a everyone here is gonna love it
premieres tonight I believe everyone
nods I definitely want to know jumping
right off the beginning talk a little
bit about how you got involved in this
story and what was it about this that
said I want to make this well I wasn't
familiar with wrestling I wasn't a
wrestling fan and the movie originated
because dear friend of mine Dwayne the
rock Johnson guys come on telling an
important story or telling the important
origin story Johnson III appeared with
him years ago in a film called tooth
fairy you're welcome and he he he and I
stayed in touch he saw a documentary on
British TV about Paige here and her real
life crazy wrestling family and thought
this has got some meat on the bone and
it could be an interesting movie it was
this story of Paige's entire family all
everyone wrestles mum dad three kids and
she and her brother Zach got the chance
to audition for WWE which I didn't
realize but for a wrestlers office
either that's the best and so they went
off to audition only Paige got signed
her brother got left behind and it what
unfolded after that was a very movie
lifting emotional funny story which
we've made into a film with this
wonderful cast I'm definitely curious
for the entire cast talk a little bit
about when you hear about this project
what we did you get the script where
were you told a little bit like how did
you get involved and I'm curious do you
still get nervous I'm gonna stop there
I'm gonna stop there and let you go with
that question getting nervous process
but I want to I want to separate that
and I I butchered it I do get nervous
[Laughter]
I've always wanted to do a film where I
wrestle a bit
I wrote a I've I have a wrestling film
that I've written so I mean maybe next
year if you fancy directing that one but
I think through lending and that cash
cow drying up so yeah I mean it's nice
to do a wrestling film it's nice to get
involved and it's a true story and you
know you get to enjoy a better
rough-and-tumble I like a bit of
rough-and-tumble sleep as you know and
this ticked all the boxes
I get nervous do you what next time I'd
have more microphones right listen we're
this is a very punk-rock operation
where's Mikey and I hear they got tons
of cash right we only have five readers
a month on Collider and so it's a very
limited budget oh this is a waste of
time then I guess what I'll go to the
other question I had which is that you
obviously act a little bit but I am
curious about the audition process and
when you are getting ready to cast and
what those meetings are like because
you've been on the other end and you
know what it's like to walk in the room
and be scared about you know trying to
land a role
I never audition because people just
come to me and I just say yea or nay
no I'm very conscious and I don't I I
tried quite hard to and I'm sure these
actors will tell you that I fail but I
tried to make them feel comfortable and
relaxed as I know how stressful it is
and I don't want this to be a job
interview it's just an opportunity for
us to figure out you know if we're gonna
do this together and so I yeah but I
mean I feel like they should say should
answer on on that aspect yeah yeah and
feel free to speak honestly it's a
wrestling you're in a motel room I
didn't think it it it really actually
helped that Steve's an actor and a
really good actor thank you me because
if ever we got stuck Steve would just do
it
he'd go why don't you just do it like
this and I think some actors are a
little bit precious about that sometimes
and it's not it's that's all ho Steve
would direct just sometimes he would go
actually it's funny if you did this and
so you would just take his word for it
and go I'm not gonna argue with that
especially when you can watch it it's
he's I think because he's such a good
actor it's a brilliant shortcut twice he
said that I think that's why I think
that I will also say that one of the
best things about the audition process
was that he just got Jack and I in a
room and we just did all of our the the
siblings most important and and
difficult and hearty scenes which meant
that straightaway it kind of tapped into
whether or not I suppose we could
actually be siblings and that was really
refreshing to kind of dive in the deep
end and actually get some of those
scenes understood and I really enjoyed
that day it was a good day well you did
a great job very much apparently so yeah
talk a little bit about do you did you
have to audition for this I had lunch
with Stephen yeah a late lunch and then
I was ashamed as we read some scene yeah
yeah yeah
a lot of a lot of actors that we use
have seen their work a lot I've heard
it's just a meeting well it should have
been just a meeting and Lina it's
certainly you know has aren't just a
meeting but I like to throw down an
audition because then when you show up
if you got the job
via an audition it's gonna be a better
job yeah I I'm a little bit weird about
do you wanna I'm always like no I want
to play the game of seeing who is the
best thing for their like that and this
part being that so personally what I'm
sure you're doing that because you know
it offers you if people have seen Lina
before it's not the obviously think of
her as a Norwich
you know a Norwich working-class
wrestler whereas you know it's obvious
with Nick I definitely want to know what
it was like those first time you guys
sat down and what those discussions were
like and maybe what he told you about
what he wanted to do well it obviously
start off with Dwayne bringing the whole
movie idea of which completely blew my
mind and then he end up telling me that
Stephen was going to be director and
writer of it which also blew my mind
because I love you know he's fantastic
so I go to meet him in person I think it
was at WrestleMania and SummerSlam - he
came along and and he was just very
passionate about what he liked he fell
in love with the project you know and
and it's gonna it's gonna you're gonna
see it when she watched a movie is
fantastic but yeah I was like definitely
interesting just seeing like this
massive Gilad bare mind she's met the
wrong sort of the neuro painful
I definitely curious about the editing
process and I'm it because ultimately
that's the final rewrite I'm curious
what you learned in the editing room and
that and maybe early any early
screenings that impacted the finished
film well I as I said earlier was not a
wrestling fan and I became knowledgeable
and a fan over the course of making the
film but I wanted to make a film that
was for the booth the wrestling fan and
four pages existing
fans but also for people like me you've
never seen wrestling and it was
important that you enjoyed it even if
you have never watched wrestling and but
but but consequently you we had to try
and explain in the body of the film
certain key things you need to know
about wrestling in order to sort of
fully understand the movie and the kind
of emotional payoff of the film and so a
lot of the editing was just figuring out
how much do people need to know in order
to understand and enjoy the film you
know I mean and there was a lot of
back-and-forth just in terms of you know
information and explaining and it was it
was sort of surprisingly painstaking you
know just trying to get that balance
right how long what I think a lot of
people don't realize is the shoot might
only be like two months but the editing
process could be a year right so could
you talk about how long did it take to
shoot and how long was the depict at
what was it in making the entire film it
was a long process but you're actually
shooting what was it two two months and
then yeah editing must have gone on for
at least six it feels like yeah and he
was just it was a very complicated thing
we had this giant fight at the end which
we shot at the Staples Center in
Florence went out there in front of
20,000 fans so we had you know about I
don't know 12 WWE cameras three of our
own and we had these guys watching it at
home and we had all this footage we had
to try and melt together into this big
fight with a commentator explaining what
was going on it was a really when you
see the film it looks kind of effortless
when you've seen kind of giant Marvel
movies where you see can you can see all
the special effects but it would this
was a weirdly painstaking tough film to
edit for for all of you guys for the
actors I'm curious you read the script
you're getting ready to film what's the
scene that you're most excited to do or
scared shitless definitely the wrestling
scene that one was in the script that's
where the storyline is going towards and
then obviously doing it we're doing it
for real in front of a real audience not
a paid audience and in front of
wrestling fans and that even when I
watch it just it makes my skin hot it's
it was amazing but terrifying and we did
it in the first week of shoot so it was
like yeah yeah for real at the Staples
Center
do you like this we have to shoot this
in week one are you kidding me a little
bit yeah yeah because usually by the
time you do those magazines you're kind
of a little bit more in the Nervii hook
actor but we had that day and even from
when we got ready when we started
getting ready and we started wrestling
and working out there was always that
date that we needed to have the main
fight ready and prepared and and glossed
and beautiful by the time that we
started and it was like up on the fourth
day of shoot yeah but it then when it
was done I really in I could like enjoy
the rest of the story in the shoot
because I didn't have that mega thing
hanging over me well you did a mazing
job I was saying when we when I first
watched film I was in tears and just
standing up cheering the first page
which was amazing feeling and I think I
just felt a little bit of pressure
playing Paige's mom because she's
amazing and I'd watch the documentary
years ago and fallen in love with them
and then it this came up like 10 years
later and I was like [ __ ] yeah I love
that family they're bonkers
so sort of pressure of doing a good job
I think was all the way through for me
so I didn't enjoy minute of it no I did
I'm joking I think I was I wanted to
wrestle I really wanted to do the
wrestling and I think immediately I
think I'm often i under play and i'm
kind of naturalistic but being a you
know being ricky and being a wrestler
enables you to be really big comedic lee
when you're interacting with the
audience and you know like reacting to
zack zodiacs entry entrance music you
know there's I think the key was say let
the audience know everything you're
thinking you know what I mean that's so
it was good to be big you know comedian
Lee in that way
I don't out but the new Kia telly route
2019 station wagon is out now it's out
in September right now I guess yeah I
was least nervous before the shoot about
the wrestling stuff because because of
watching a lot of wrestling beforehand I
thought and it looks so easy like these
guys make it look so easy so I was Lisa
nervous about that but then the very
first time I tried it I thought oh [ __ ]
there's a hell of a lot to think about
rather than just running and charging
each other and making all the noise like
it's so technical these guys they're
mental work they have to so it's a very
caring I found you know it's all about
looking after one another and even
though it yes you're beating the [ __ ]
out of each other but there's that weird
unspoken thing where you know what kill
each other you know there were little
techniques we were taught which was just
about being kind to one another visit
you know protect each other in the mean
time yeah and in order to you have to
protect one another in each move that
you do no matter who's like winning in
that move or who's losing it's
completely formed on trust and that was
like I think the main thing that Jack
and I learned in the first month of
training was you can't do this fight
unless you're both completely up to it
and you're both completely 100% and you
both know what you're doing because it's
so lethal if you don't and not as yet as
you said that's a really nice touch to
beating the [ __ ] out of one another it
was also like a day where you heard like
20-25 wrestlers in and we but we were
shooting a scene before and they were
all scattered around this ring they just
hanging about like you know bats just
hanging off the wall just giving sort of
approving and disapproving nods which
which just made it even more terrifying
didn't really help at all yeah sorry
about that actors say I'm very curious
when did you see the film for the first
time and was did you see anything you
know you give a like was there any like
note given like this is great but yeah
so I just returned from because I was
out with neck injury right so I just
returned back to the performance I know
where everyone is training to become a
superstar
so it was like rehabilitation and Steven
came in and it was just Steven and he
goes okay I have the movie for you and
this was like October 2017
it was then so he brought it in and he
set it up and like this nice like
private room and then he was like but I
can't sit with you so I'm just gonna let
you watch this by yourself because I
feel like I'm gonna keep looking at year
and see if you actually like the movie
or not gonna make you mad you look just
like cry my eyes so we left the room and
then I text him off to the movie and I'm
just like can you please just come in
here because I don't want to go outside
right now like I was crying my eyes out
like I couldn't I couldn't watch it the
first time cuz it was so good and it was
just so surreal and it was just it was
incredible it was an amazing movie
everyone just like hit out the pocket
was liking it was beautiful and then I
watched it again just a few months ago
and I thought it was terrible and [ __ ] a
lot of notes and I thought it was
actually pretty good
he said that's me alia knows like oh
really it's actually pretty good I think
it was did I get myself in trouble all
the time exactly but I watched it again
and this time I could really like take
it in and see it and it was just like
wow it's like even better the first time
I watched it and I don't see Stephen
poking his head over the window right I
am what was it like for you when she's
watching it art because you've obviously
put years into this movie so are you
sitting there like chewing on fingers
are you like no I we nailed this no I
was nervous because I and I showed it to
her family as well independently and you
know um it's it's it's it's ultimately I
think an inspiring a lifting story but
if it's also a story that has pain in it
and it has really emotion and and you
know she and her brother and her family
went through ups and downs during the
course of her her experience and so you
know although I think we have a kind of
triumphant sort of rocky ending you know
there's a lot of emotion there along the
way and and so to sort of reflect that
back to real people and to sort of take
them back through some difficult times I
felt both a responsibility and a sort of
nervousness about that but also I you
know I I didn't want to sort of
sugarcoat it you know cuz I wanted it to
be as authentic as it could be to their
experiences because that's sort of what
I'd responded to when I heard about the
story you know so um but they seemed
very pleased I mean um Ricky who Nick
plays in the film was very disappointed
that there was Nick playing it he wanted
you won't read with you won't really
exactly they're true
well Ray wasn't available James Corden
couldn't do it the fat guy off the
office no he's like very old school he
like looks Laurel and Adi
he likes Laurel and Hardy like he likes
something good and he does love ray
winstone so he was unfamiliar with Nick
Frost fs and I was like he's an amazing
actor tad like you have to watch his day
he's incredible
a desert route don't know happy about
this right so then he finally watched it
and then you just like wow it's really
good I'm gonna get right to cool yeah so
I can go home yeah Ray's got a false
beard about your process though on set
and what you've learned through your
career in terms of maybe how it's
changed like the way you'd like to work
uh well the thing that Mike the thing I
constantly forget to do is compliment my
actors I yeah I am I always feel that if
I've not said that was terrible then it
means I'm incredibly happy and where do
you actually tell people that was
terrible no but I think but no of course
not
no no I do much more delicately and
suddenly I guess I sort of I'm more
insidious let's go again let's say this
opportunity to congratulate and thank
everyone for their terrific work because
you know we're very busy was it was it
was a tight fast shoot you know wasn't a
big-budget movie and I haven't got a lot
of time to massage these people's eCos
you know I mean who's massaging my ego
no one but no in all sources I think
over time I I think I've learned that
you you you you have to sort of trust
the actors and you also have to listen
to the actors I think the more I perform
myself the more I realize that does
matter if you've written it and if
you've carefully planned it when the
actors start acting and living in that
space and doing that stuff saying those
words or moving
in certain ways they know when
something's not feeling right or not
feeling authentic or and so you have to
trust that when they say this
something's not right here
it's not because they're being a diva
it's because they're on to something you
know and and and sort of listening to
that and hearing that is is the greatest
thing I've learned I think I was gonna
say I mean most people are in a diva but
there's one guy who might be give me a
mic here one of the things though and
this is when you're making this is based
obviously on your story and these are
all real events but you're also making a
movie so you have to balance that line
of like fact versus fiction can you sort
of talk about you know making sure that
you you know what you're willing to
embellish on or is it everything that
actually happened no it's actually very
accurate I love it like obviously some
things have to be dramatized for this
but I would say like a really really big
portion of it is extremely accurate so
you'll you'll you'll see you have to go
watch it there was indeed a UFO no um
well like I the the the very end scene
she delivers this amazing promo at the
unit and is my words but as in like
separate occasions like different
promotes that I did throughout my career
and they kind of combined them all
together to make this one incredible
perma and I'm like well damn I wish I
did deliver that was fantastic
and if your fight it was show and that's
actually something that's so amazing
when watching your fight you can see how
like excited but tired and and how
thrilling it is and you are so emotional
and that little speech that you do
backstage where you're just saying how
it all is worth it how it all all of it
makes sense now that is what exactly
what you try to achieve you may remember
you give an interview since you've come
out for you talk about since I've been
on this long journey and my family oh my
god and you say it's so perfect like
considering what you've just done and
it's not rehearsed it
not something that you've got ready it's
just coming completely from here and
it's like at that point you go oh my god
yet they you go through so much to get
there and you lose so much to get there
and so yeah it's it is your words yeah
the thing with WWE is that you're once
you win a championship the first thing
they do is they shove a camera in your
face and you look here just like you
don't prepared for anything you're just
like oh okay and so like you can't help
but speak from the heart then I remember
that interviewer sweaty mess all these
girls are running up to me like yeah and
it's like my first day on the main
roster you know and I was just like I
was just so overwhelmed and I was just
so happy I was like man we finally did
it this little girl from Norwich finally
did it and yeah I just I can't wait for
you guys to see that ensino because she
just delivers it so perfectly it's
really beautiful
it made people cry that don't usually
crack was it not like one take flawed
flawed at that speech in front of 20,000
people in one take I think wasn't it
yeah you do mean do we take it with any
wrestling no we did we read took the
wrestling and then we had I think it was
one monologue right that's that's your
one that was full of the same it felt
like you were full of the same emotion
she yeah and we had we had a great time
doing it was so exciting and for those
like eight minutes at the fight I truly
understood what it meant to want to get
back in there and you are a superhuman
for those eight minutes and you can do
anything and it makes so much sense once
you're in there I want to say congrats
on the movie thank you sincerely so much
for coming in thank you Kia Telluride
for being an awesome sponsor have fun at
the premiere tonight thanks so much
thank you
you